what we're going to do in this video is
think about limits involving
trigonometric functions so let's just
start with a fairly straightforward one
let's find the limit as X approaches PI
of sine of X pause the video and see if
you can figure this out well with both
sine of X and cosine of X they are
defined for all real numbers so their
domain is all real numbers you can put
any real number in here
for X and it will give you an output it
is defined and they are also continuous
over their entire domain in fact all the
trigonometric functions are continuous
over their entire domain and so for sine
of X because it's continuous and it's
defined at sine of PI we would say that
this is the same thing as sine of PI and
sine of PI you might already know is
equal to 0 and we can do a similar
exercise with cosine of X so if I were
to say what's the limit as X approaches
I'll just take an arbitrary angle X
approaches PI over 4 of cosine of X well
once again cosine of X is defined for
all real numbers X can be any real
number it's also continuous so for
cosine of X this limit is just going to
be cosine of PI over 4 and that is going
to be equal to square root of 2 over 2
this is one of those useful angles to
know the sine and cosine of it so if you
think in degrees this was a 45 degree
angle and in general if I'm dealing with
a sine or cosine the limit as X
approaches a of sine of X is equal to
sine of a once again this is going to be
true for any a any real number a and I
can make a similar statement about
cosine of X limit as X approaches a of
cosine of X is equal to cosine of a now
I've been saying it over and over that's
because both of their domains are all
real numbers they are defined for all
real numbers that you put in and they're
continuous on there
entire domain but now let's do slightly
more involved trigonometric functions or
ones that aren't defined for all real
numbers that their domains are
constrained just a little bit more so
let's say if we were to take the limit
as X approaches PI of tangent of X what
is this going to be equal to well this
is the same thing as the limit as X
approaches PI tangent of X is sine of X
over cosine of X and so both of these
are defined for pi and so we could just
substitute PI in and we just want to
ensure that we don't get a zero in the
denominator because that would make it
undefined so we get sine of PI over
cosine of PI which is equal to 0 over
negative 1 which is completely fine if
it was negative 1 over 0 would be in
trouble but this is just going to be
equal to 0 so that works out but if I
were to ask you what is the limit as X
approaches PI over 2 of tangent of X
pause the video and try to work that out
well think about it this is the limit as
X approaches PI over 2 of sine of X over
cosine of X now sine of PI over 2 is 1
but cosine of PI over 2 is 0 so if you
were to just substitute it in this would
give you 1 over 0 and one way to think
about it is PI over 2 is not in the
domain of tangent of X and so this limit
actually turns out it doesn't exist in
general if we're dealing with sine
cosine tangent or cosecant secant or
cotangent if we're taking a limit to a
point that is in their domain then the
value of the limit is going to be the
same thing as the value of the function
at that point if you're taking a limit
to a point that's not in their domain
there's a good chance that we're not
going to have a limit so here there is
no limit and a way to deduce that is
that PI over 2 is not in tangent of X is
domain if you were to graph tan of X you
would see a vertical asymptote at PI
over 2 let's do one more of these so
let's say the limit as X approaches PI
of cotangent of X pause the video and
see if you can figure out what that's
going to be well one way to think about
it cotangent of X it's one over tangent
of X it's cosine of X over sine of X
it's a little bit this is limit as X
approaches PI of this and is PI in the
domain of cotangent of X well though if
you were to just substitute PI in you're
going to get negative 1 over 0 and so
that is not in the domain of cotangent
of X if you were to plot it you would
see a vertical asymptote right over
there
and so we have no limit so we have no
limit so once again this is not in the
domain of that and so good chance that
we have no limit when the take thing
we're taking the limit to is in the
domain of the trigonometric function
we're going to have a defined limit and
sine and cosine in particular are
defined for all real numbers and they're
continuous over all real numbers so you
take the limit to anything for them it's
going to be defined and it's going to be
the value of the function at that point